foreign
[Music]
but for the sake of the camera you sure
you don't want legal representation I
don't need it I can tell you that you've
been arrested on suspicion of conspiracy
to abduct Leo Newman
nope it's obviously been some
we can't be certain whether this is
terrorist related politically motivated
or simple extortion young guy Leo Newman
gets packed into a Suitcase by a mass
dance
NYPD flags for suspects
Catherine Newman I cannot imagine what
you're going through at the moment I
love my son
and I want him back
I don't know why what do we have in
common we're all British and we were all
in New York on The Daily only one was
kidnapped do we look like kidnappers do
you what does a kidnapper look like you
without any proof of our innocence the
damage is already done
you sure you know what you're doing you
know but I can't go back nobody buys me
as a mother
I'll always be a CEO first play it long
there's no other option first page in
the Playbook except I don't remember the
chapter on the kidnap of your only child
you're being asked to communicate in
order to free your only child these
people want you to tell the truth we're
getting deeper in that is still a choice
that people may understand everything
we've done until now
you have underestimated these people
right from the beginning
[Music]
foreign
the truth will come out
[Music]